[Music]
you
all right everybody welcome everybody to
the class this is Grandmaster Alex
Lenderman here are presenting the
viewers Choice lecture and we're gonna
start with the game from one of our
members here or Perry I know what I like
against on a Krishna Rao and the person
we're looking at their game is playing
white do we have Perry here should we
wait for him because he was asking
so in the meantime let's quickly see
what happened there it was kind of turn
transpose into or CARICOM c5 Knight c3
classical variation of the CARICOM and
blackberry six which is a little bit
unusual typically they do this this and
the Bishop f5 mm-hmm oh he's okay you
know what what happened okay I see okay
so I'll do that game anyway then okay
fine
so Knight c3 de yeah so de is the main
line after which in this Carrick on line
black has three main lines 97 Bishop f5
and Knight of 6 however in the game
black played e6 which i think is just
too passive it's like combining the
French and the CARICOM which doesn't
make too much sense just closing in the
bishop I mean if you wanted to play the
French then c6 is definitely not to move
to place so this is like a bad hybrid
white play not show continuing
development Bishop before Bishop d3
makes a lot of sense
there is also move e5 which gains space
considering that for black to challenge
the space c5 would be lost of a temple
because of Bishop d2 and where it's just
the loss of a temple compared solve the
main lines so Bishop d3 is fine though
and now black played another race
strange move h6 I think at this point he
should at least do this and play Knight
of 6 instead h6 was played a white
castles 97 mistre 4 I just 6 Bishop g3
the shove d6 Queen d2 arm yeah so this
was already a very good position for
white because black basically violated a
lot of principles normally we're taught
as beginners to develop pieces but in
this game black didn't do that
lost couple of temples and now white
could probably already go for you know
opening up the center with Edie black
might take CD because if you do it II
then it's even worse you can give check
and then you don't even have a good way
to stop the check because after this 95
is coming you know threatening this
Queen t3 and so on and so forth so black
played CD block probably play CD but
then once again you do this very
important idea and then the white is now
much better because you get now full
control over the five square which is
now an outpost and if black tries to
save the porn for example with a move
like king of seven then white will win
with just ninety five so black probably
will have to lose the pawn with castling
and then okay you have an extra pawn and
a better position so this was probably
the way to go for white just simply
going for the exchange in the center and
then exchanging the night and then just
soon has only developed night basically
in the game trading of blacks developed
pieces and also creating bunch of
weaknesses for black skin in the game
white played Queen d2 which is also an
acceptable move a developing move but
it's a little bit slower and gives black
a chance to kind of stabilize a little
bit more black took on g3 it probably
was also fine to castle Bishop takes g3
H takes g3 in this particular position
that was maybe interesting to take with
the F pawn to potentially open up that F
file [ __ ] specs g3 h6 g3 and now h5 a
very desperate move trying to go for an
attack with h4 but the thing is once
again with very with such poor
development usually such attacks will
just not work
so it was natural that white played 865
seat xd5 when rookie one once again I
think this this idea would have been
very nice for white here very nicely
five square bishop and c8 is blocked in
bad piece weaknesses white is
strategically winning here rookie one
was played h4 and now white made a I
guess a blunder with Knight 65 so in
this position once again this simple
move and then you could take here Knight
takes everything is good but for some
reason white took here so must have been
a blind spot somewhere because black
just simply takes back the piece and now
you know his little piece interestingly
enough though despite that white is
still probably okay because his position
was so good before that that even this
position is unclear so now white
correctly took on g6 took on g6 and then
played 95 better move might have been to
play C 4 with the obvious intention that
if you take you go rook c1 and you win
the bishop thanks to the skewer so black
probably plays somewhere with the Queen
and now you can take an H for the reason
that maybe was good to include lc4
because have two takes right away I
don't know maybe will blacken castle and
the queen is now comfortable centralized
here so it's probably good idea to drive
that Queen away with a move like a c4 or
even rocky five in the game 95 was
played and now black found a good move
pounced on his opportunity played h3
taking advantage of Queen very
well-placed and now creating some mate
made threats towards white white / f3
now this is a concession because that
creates potentially weaknesses to his
own king as well black played h2
I think that's move as a mistake from a
practical standpoint of view because now
white can blocked at porn and that
really eliminates a lot of blacks
attacking possibilities its loses those
flexibility the thing is a white is not
really threatening to take on h3
lack in the meantime has flexibility and
he might take on g2 or he might go H to
in some cases why remove that
flexibility why not just play move like
96 completing the development
challenging this beautiful night
attacking the porn just a very natural
move and putting the ball in white
scorch seeing how white reacts to it
white can take on g6 sure but now after
rock age 694 now you can go h2 King edge
one Queen takes d4 and black is much
better in some other cases of white
let's say takes here you can take with
the queen with again better position but
okay black latex - still better for
black but now he played a big mistake
once again it always makes sense to look
for a move where you develop and you
also defend and also counter play you
see this night only five is basically at
this point White's
most dangerous piece so it's always a
good idea to look for moves which would
remove opponent's best pieces in the
game either you have to look for a way
to attack it but in this case you cannot
attack it so at least you try to trade
it off anael and also developing your
own piece along the way and again taking
on g6 it's just a little inconvenience
you just go to H for a night of four
take hereand black is totally in control
here instead of that rogue h6 was played
a very big mistake defending that porn
which really was very weak anyway but
not taking care of his main issue which
is the Queen side development it's in
very very bad shape and he's playing
with the piece that's already developed
just to defend the pawn a very very big
mistake
so now white to play and what should
white play white found a very good move
here Queen of for threatening Queen f7
fall between f8 follow the Queen takes
g7 excellent move by white now in this
position suddenly white is winning why
just has a winning attack black cannot
defend against all the
so you see how one greedy move like that
can change the whole evaluation even
when you're up a piece so black played
King g7 that doesn't really help his
case call a case in a new kind of way
Queen f7 King d6 and white played rugby
one I think rogue do you wanna certainly
doesn't spoil the win but it was much
more clinical to just go here and then
go Queen decks g7 win winning that
material winning that rook and winning
the game if you're looking for like
purely the best mathematical way to play
it was c4
because the Queen is suddenly in really
really really short on squares if you go
here after room d1 you lose the Queen
and after Queen takes takes material it
might look like it's equal but White has
made in one uniform not a surprise King
being on e5 in the middle of the board
white as Queen in the rock attacking and
black has completely in the undeveloped
pieces all over the place so black would
have to go Queen a5 if he doesn't want
to lose the Queen but now White has a
horse mating attack c5 check King g5
Queen a 4 and 24 checkmate is threatened
the only way you can stop Tomatoes by
just giving up pieces and that will just
prolong the mates so that was the best
way to play just go for the attack
simply creating some new adding some new
forces with the ponent the king is
completely dead Ruby Jiwon is definitely
a slow move but the position is so good
that it's still completely winning for
white Bishop d7 now c4 was played very
good Queen f5 and now white played a
pretty big mistake going for the spawn
which really is irrelevant driving that
night from such a good square much
better would have been a move like
Windex g7 attacking the rook or even
better is you see the king and the rook
you know there's a reason we brought
that look on a D file is that we have to
try to open up the lines
King is open we need to try to look for
ways to open up the lines so the best
way to play here would have been d5
exclam and this is just toast from luck
there's just simply no way to prevent
white from having a killer attack this
you know this you know even variations
are not necessary here it's just clear
that black is completely toast in many
different ways
Knight 66 was definitely you know still
winning for white but definitely losing
the threat 96 c5 King c7 rook takes c6 I
think instead of Knight a six black
should maybe try a move like King c7
trying to flee with the king as soon as
possible or maybe even a move like rook
takes g6 just trying to somehow get rid
of White's night and try to somehow try
to survive here it's completely lost but
it's not at least made right away and
step 96 was played c5 King c7 and our
white took which is fine Queen takes a
two and now white went for a line that's
completely winning and it's perfectly
fine rook takes rook c6 winning the
Queen and usually when you see a winning
line like that it's okay to just go for
it
but for the big scheme of things Queen
of four was the best move it actually
led to mate if King d8 we got queen of a
check King c7 and who can find the mate
from here
sorry
what did you say
okay
White has a forced checkmate in three
moves no matter what black does Queen d6
is correct now black has two moves King
g8 and King c8 let's look at King g8
first white to play maiden - yes ma'am
rocky eight very good brilliant giving
up at rook in order to lure the King
into the vulnerable square and now White
has checkmate in one and two ways Queen
d7 or queen a fait same kind of mate
what about King c8 yes
very good so this was a forced mate
that's why you have to always look for
checks it might be made Queen a4 very
nice geometry queen of four then King d8
king c8 doesn't matter
check queen comes in here and then only
we have rookie 897 so this was a very
nice geometrical mating motive here
which was better than what was played in
the game but rook c6 is also not bad
also winning and black-white king b7 I
guess yeah so maybe if king c6 then 95
was of course the problem so BC was
played takes king b7 Queen b3 King here
95 and this is a winning position white
is up Queen 4 rock in the night but more
importantly White's King is completely
safe blacks King is not and black is
totally busted
rugby 8 Queen f7 rook t8 and rock a one
perfectly good move at acting that night
and there's really no way for black to
defend the position his position is kind
of on its last legs
so black tried a few more moves but the
rest of the game was never in doubt
and here black resigned
so it was all over all over a nice game
and especially nice recovery because you
know psychologically when we just make a
kind of a strange blunder like that
blunder a piece sometimes it's hard to
you know mentally regroup but it seems
like white played a very good game even
after blundering that minor piece ok
does anyone have any questions on this
game
[Music]
all right now I'm gonna ask you guys
another question has any one of you here
submitted a game like maybe you know
within a month ago or maybe two weeks
ago last week or any point because I
wanted to because I know that I see
about a lot of games here so are any of
these games by any chance your games if
not then I'll go with the game I have in
my score sheet and we'll go over that
game because that's one of the people
who sitting here alright so let's go
again let's turn on and let's see
control three okay that means one second
you get rid of that thing okay perfect
okay so the game was d4 Knight of 6 c4
g6
said who who can tell us what the
opening is called Kings Indian very good
yes so what white is Caleb gostin and
with black it's Peter what Rupert yes
okay so so farts were following mainline
theory here and black played c5 which is
perfectly normal move here D 597 I'm not
a big expert on the theory here instead
of 97 I think he six is also move and
enough Knight of three to take this and
then if you take you play rook e8 Bishop
of 597 and maybe at some point try 494
I've seen this played before and if CD
also rooky 892 and then you got kind of
a Benoni type position which might be
okay I mean the still requires precise
play but that's might be another
alternative also maybe there is
something to be said about h6 inclusion
but 97 is certainly reasonable move
Knight f3 h6 Bishop d2
a six castles
Queen c7
h3
and rookie aides so you were suggesting
v6 instead maybe trying to go Bishop e7
but I'm not sure I think rook e8 makes
some sense to try to play for six and
then maybe try to take but in general my
belief is that in these positions that
unless blood creates counterplay you're
kind of cramped in these positions
so I played Bishop f4 so his idea is now
Knight h5 is met by the stage two that's
why he played h3 first and then go to
GaN dish before in this position black
played 95 ok I think the move is
somewhat reasonable Knight 65 9065
Bishop g3 okay so why just wants to play
a four apparently so black played an
interesting move here g5 the move is
actually very interesting because even
though it weakens the square it's very
hard for y to take advantage of it
number one number two maybe at some
point this will come and number three it
stops a force so the move is you know
deserves a deserving attention at least
h4g 4 makes a lot of sense you know not
opening up the lines for a white Queen
d2
now if f3 I'm guessing Knight h5 was
your intention right so that was
certainly an official one you can even
go g3 saw was thinking gave Queen e1
maybe you know white could have gone
through this line and it seems like
maybe widest a little bit better because
white is opening up some lines ah
Queen d2 was played 9 h5 & Quincy once
so definitely seemed like here a white
kind of lost a thread
nights xg3 of course it makes sense not
to repeat moves because then white will
pounce inopportune then play another
move like f3 so takes takes h5 you know
and now I think black is actually doing
okay because this Bishop has kind of
shut down and you're actually kind of
stabilized Queen d2 f6 good move ideas
prophylaxis against Queen g5 rook ad 126
another good move prophylaxis against d6
and here it's as equals so GG did you
offer a draw in this position mm-hmm
yeah because I know sometimes when you
write on a score should equals that
means you know it's okay got it got it
nine a for Bishop d7 94 was also a
strange move Queen eight five and out
luck is better because b5 was a nice
move played and now white is
he played 93 so if he goes might be six
what would you do
quincy seven years and then he has to
find the move before otherwise he is
losing with Robbie eight and and then
he's threatening this and then you take
and then it's still very double-edged
after move the King h2 to protrude and
c5 and get out of check position is a
mess
anyone's game there's even an
interesting possibility that the engines
are just not sure how good there is
another higher depth but before right
away sacrificing the piece you have to
go there and then c6 and you go there
and Roby one Queen a 75 and okay I mean
it's one of these lines which it's very
hard to evaluate this position during
the game and I think from practical
standpoint of view it's like roughly
equal chances but yeah I mean a
certainly during game it looks dangerous
but it looks like you're not losing at
least it's holdable but still b5 was
good it's principle move and your
opponent just played 93 which is
certainly now you're doing very well now
you played before so I'm wondering here
I would be I would be thinking very
seriously here to try to keep the
tension here because as at the moment I
don't think he's threatening a Seabee
because you just take a beam the queen
is very poorly placed so why not just
play move like this page six the idea
being to try to come in here so he might
go king of two and then you know you go
King g7 I mean what this does is it just
keeps the tension because in some cases
you might want to go before in some
cases you might want to take open up the
B file but he's not really threatening
to take unbe five so why not just keep
the tension I would also be thinking
about the move like rugby eight that to
me seems like a human move and let him
figure out how to play this position
it's not easy but I would do all that
without the move before I just think
it's not necessary because he's not
threatening to take and you have
potentially in some cases options of
taking on c4 which he has to worry about
which I think makes your play a little
bit even a little bit easier well that's
true
I mean before certainly a logical idea
but again I would keep the tension
because sometimes it's good to try to
open up the B file so 91 in Bishop h6
King h2 Bishop e3 route III this should
be four
this should be one rookie b8 so what
didn't you like about grabbing the spawn
right here
oh I see so it was one of these double
blunders which seems like both players
missed okay so you played rugby eight
and now he played Bishop a4 and you play
the King g7 okay so besides the idea of
taking the pawn and b2 so first of all
if you do take the pawn and b2 I guess
there's takes and takes so that's one of
the reasons why not to do that however
there's a very interesting moment here
where you had an opportunity to maybe
get a very big advantage but it's so
with the move that's very hard to find
this should be five keeping the tension
just King g7 and seeing what he will do
because he's kind of - also stuck in a
way okay so let's say he plays rook F so
what how does he play this position yeah
in this position
kingi six
yeah rook a5 and now maybe you can try
to offer a queen trait and then when you
do trade Queens you still cannot really
take on b5 because you're gonna take and
then you have pressure on the a file and
then you you know you could try to at
some point break through slowly but of
course such a position anyway it's kind
of that's why I wouldn't have played
before because once you play before you
kind of take away some chances to but
okay King g7 still not not a not a big
mistake
yeah yeah exactly all know that makes
makes a lot of sense it's certainly very
logical no he did he did he went King G
692 and now for some reason again ok
well now there should be two Queen c5 so
you play Queen d6 and he played Knight B
3 so maybe that's why it was better to
go Queen d8 actually just offer the
exchange and then if he takes you're
just in a position where you have no
losing chances and if he goes Queen f4
then you can take and b2 so I think this
would have been much better
Queen g6 though it does give him a
chance to play 93 and you're still kind
of then you have to trade off your
Bishop and then you have to either allow
c5 or e5 so it seems like win d6 was a
mistake and now you traded Queens still
you're completely fine
ya know but if you're satisfied with the
drawer then I think you should have
played lines like Bishop b5 where you
can't break through so night 64 eat 64
kimchi 105 here maybe it made sense to
play e6 yay 5 also well if you if your
goal is to make a draw then then if I've
probably just makes it because you can't
really take it because you take and well
no oh sorry sorry
no you actually you go rook c8 first and
then you take that yeah and then you're
still much better
yeah he cuz you couldn't defend it and
then he's just like in a bad position he
has a weak 494 he just has a bunch of
weaknesses but yeah his six was probably
objectively better because after this
you can go rocky eight then you're
threatening to take and if anyone's
better it's you
you played a five he played Rock G one
you played a for rope DF 1 B 3 a 3
and now oh yeah here it looks like yeah
you should have played a five even if it
doesn't quite work but it's at least
that's complicated and it's okay for you
but here you play the rook c8
and that wolf was a mistake because
white now could play oh yeah well I was
sorry it was d8 but that's a mistake why
because white can now play which move
except for you what's the best move for
white now why is the smooth inaccurate
Rock d8 ah yes very good now white plays
d5 and he gets a better position but
instead eeeh in the game after rook g8
rook one of two was played and now it
was rook h8 so still both players
missing the idea
I now he played he can also play five
but he played d6 which is also good
because now if eg rook takes f6 and
after rook takes rook here and now the
king is exactly where it belongs and
look one here yeah and the rest of the
game is not notated but here blacks
position is falling apart White's King
is just on g3 comfortably located right
yeah so he's a master okay yeah no he's
a good player I know he drew and I am in
a tournament now so no that was a pretty
decent game against Calif especially the
early part where you pretty much wore on
target with a lot of critical moments so
who can tell us what were some of the
main critical lessons you know we can
learn from this game some instructive
moments that you can catch pick up on
from this game
just some braids
um sir what was that again yeah bond
breaks right mm-hmm
any other yes
start
mm-hmm
yeah well I think to me the main
takeaway is I think just more often than
not calculating more more than one move
ahead because basically from what I
could tell um in this game every time he
had like a one move idea like a clear
idea you were you saw that you stopped
it
Queen g5 d6 you were able to stop it but
you know when it came down so let's say
you know evaluating something that's
like two moves deep let's let's say for
example move like a five where you have
to kind of you know see you know see
line like this which is like couple of
moves deeper you know it kind of like
not stopping the line too soon after
this thing oh it looks unclear it looks
wiles let me just play something else
but you know actually looking at a
deeper and evaluating more carefully and
comparing it to the other line and
realizing that another line it's also
going to be suffering it's not just a
draw that there is some winning plant
for white and you know or all say or
even in this position kind of seeing
deeper that you know this kind of line
you have you don't have to take
automatically on e6 you could go rook c8
and then you can't really defend that
and you're just better so I think a lot
of it is just calculating a bit deeper
calculating to tree moves ahead
in critical lines because I know that
for example one of the main difference I
notice in between let's say class
players around your level 16 17 1800 and
let's say masters is precisely that just
not stopping variations and calculating
a bit deeper certain lines and not make
quick conclusions and also it's a matter
of keeping the tension you know creating
more problems I think you kind of you
know had the right grip on a lot of
positional ideas but then again you know
you kind of stopped because you saw the
idea but again here you're concretely
attacking the poor and after
this you could just defend it and here
you can never lose so it's like if you
really want a draw but this would be a
perfect way to do that because here he's
actually completely stuck and okay you
might not see how to break through but
once you put the King on g6 here you
really could shuffle that important
there's no way he could ever break
through because you can't ever take and
b5 and anything he tries to do he will
only over press like if he tries a three
he only opens up the B file for you
so it's like one of these where you know
not being afraid of ghosts at all this
rook a five but just again looking at a
bit deeper instead of playing the most
solid safe moving just also maybe it's
psychological just trusting yourself a
little bit more and know that you're
capable of you know playing against good
players and that maybe you don't you
even don't understand chess worse than
them but just you know calculating a bit
deeper I think it's just reminding
yourself during the game I think it's
just a matter of not not not making
quick conclusions and not stopping too
soon I think it's just you know when you
see a move that you think that is very
interesting and you like it
your intuition tells you about it you
like the way it looks and don't cut down
the variation once you see opponent's
idea because a lot of it is that you
know players would say between 1600 and
2000 they usually see opponents ideas
but you know the next step after that is
you know to evaluate whether your own
idea might be stronger it's like you
have to notice your opponent's ideas but
you cannot bow down to them you know SPF
they're you know twenty two hundred you
still have to think that your idea might
be stronger you have to have confidence
in your own ideas you have to notice
what opponent is trying to do you have
to like for every move that you're
calculating have to evaluate what
opponent might do but you don't stop
there you calculate okay what can I do
if my opponent does that you know what
you try to kind of you know find the
solution to your opponent's move and
that's why I'm saying calculate more
than one move deep deeper and that's
kind of the
hardest part in chess like the first
step is you know a beginner usually
plays the first move he sees or he or
she sees you know without like looking
for a better move without seeing what
opponent can do then the next stage is
you know kind of you know not playing
the first move you see but looking at
different options and also paying
attention to opponents ideas but the
next stage after that which you know
pretty much leads you to expert or maybe
master level is to notice okay if I do
this my opponent can do this this but
you know but what happens after that
you know is it all that clear I kind of
trying to understand if my opponent does
this what happens after that you know
it's
and that requires of course you know
calculation and that's you know once you
improve on that then your level should
definitely go up I think okay so one of
the ways that I think visualization
could be improved on is trying to solve
maybe studies you know because studies
you have to kind of a lot of
visualization with studies so and also a
lot of creativity so studies could help
with that sometimes let's start with
like the very basic ones at first are
you know also just doing more puzzles
more tactics more calculation and
another method that I know is helpful at
least I you know recommended to students
is to some students is let's say you
have and that can help with memory as
well you know remembering what you've
looked at is to let's say take a game
you know look at it for three minutes
right go through it for three minutes
and try to remember how the game was
played out and I would say for a player
you know under 2000 I would say try to
play a fifth play over 15 move game and
try to be able to recollect it and you
know be able to reproduce it but for
somebody higher than maybe it's like 20
moves and then 25 moves are for me as a
GM 30 moves in I think it depends on you
know your level and so on and so forth
some people could probably even do 40 50
move game someone like Magnus Carlsen
maybe but yeah it just depends I think
they're all different you know ways you
can improve on these kind of things but
it I think their main tools are just a
matter of really forcing that brains who
to work at it and on a regular basis and
then and during the term in game the
brain will not betray you
and of course it's psychology I mean you
have to really you know not give too
much respect to your opponents but
believe you can meet them and really
have confidence in your ideas especially
if you've studied and you know and
that's you know without that it's kind
of hard of course
forretress yeah well there's also the
dd6 idea avenged as well right there are
several ways to be broken you know as
magnus carlsen once said fortresses are
meant to be broken he doesn't believe in
fortresses I remember you know I was I
had this experience when I was playing
in 2012 in the US Championship against
Hikaru Nakamura and I had a comfortable
position but I played the eye I wanted
to draw in that game too much and I had
a opportunity to plug play for a win I
had like breakthroughs which would give
me an advantage but instead I played it
in the safest way to China just shuffle
back and forth just to get a fortress
and eventually got broken down I still
ended up getting a draw but only after
he missed like some opportunities so I
think you know fortress is only you know
you have to really be sure that there is
no way to break there because usually
passive positions kind of are meant to
be broken so usually it's only you go
for that only if you're definitely
either sure it's a draw or if you really
don't see anything better at all but
usually it's not you know what you
really want to do is to give your
opponent's like free game like that
it was a casual game right or siffredi
Oh was a rated game oh I see
interesting all right so we still have a
little bit of time so we can do a few
things we can either go over one of
these or or maybe if you guys have any
general questions for me like an opening
or anything we can certainly discuss
that as well so it really depends on
what you guys prefer to do okay ah
another game okay so let's try game from
Nicolas I don't know what game that is
but we'll go over it and see what
happens
okay so
so let's go over that game he 45 9 f3
knight c6 but should be v eh6 so this is
a real opus
you know open variation I think I've
seen this recently in some tournament d6
pretty salt oh yeah I think I saw it
Napoleon shouting played it against our
Aronian recently at the Moscow Grand
Prix that's where I saw it but I think
Aronian might have played something 96
some other move and here white played
Bishop d5 it seems a bit premature
because again why it's not really
developed and instead he's moving that
same Bishop twice which is already well
placed plus trading it off and giving a
block to Bishop advantage so I think in
this position Knight c3 was would have
been preferred just completing the
development with an equal position
oh oh I see
ah probably not because always let's so
let's say white plays a random one could
be because if you go Knight takes e4
even though white has become t5 there is
then room t8 and okay you have to still
calculate out at the sunblock t3 move
and then there's route xt5 front well
sharp position down an exchange but two
bishops so could be fine for black so
yeah I mean it's one of these things
which requires deeper calculation just
25 rupee a true T 3 so yeah okay well in
the game he played the ship t5 and now
for some reason Bishop b7 okay well I
think it was better to either go Queen
d6
playing Bishop e7 defending the poor or
maybe if you want to sack the pawn you
play it like this and then go here and
then you cannot hold on to the pawn
because if you go there you just go g6
and then you take this so or even rookie
eight play for compensation so that
would have been better but this should
be seven was very strange in this
position rook takes e5 Bishop d6 rook e1
there is maybe something to be said
about rookie 3 but rook e1 certainly
natural Queen Queen h4 g3 Queen x3 Queen
f3
and now black correctly keeps the Queens
on the board because he has an attack so
it's actually becoming very much like a
Marshall Attack Position
to bishops you know weak light squares
yeah and here white is already worse but
92 kind of makes things even worse he
should have first played wished before
and then 92 even though doubles the
porns but it would have would have
wouldn't have been as bad Bishop h3 you
could play some g4 it's not losing right
away apparently but it actually looks
very bad I mean so I don't know maybe
Bishop e3 would have been still bad for
white bishop of three Queen here and
then a5 already a very bad position for
white but this is not making it better
and now black played here although here
for some reason this was happened but
this would have been much better just
winning a piece but it's dead this
happened Queen takes g4 yeah so this was
a little strange but okay it's not much
to look at but a couple of critical
moments all right let's see this game
now another game
this is called I think the same
aspiration of the nimzo-indian I in the
names Oh game okay so this game was d4
Knight of 6 c4 e6 Knight c3 Bishop b4 a3
and this is called the same image
variation of the nimzo-indian and Knight
f3 more common here is to play for f3
for once you play a 3 once you have the
structure a white plate knight of three
black played b6 white lady 3 I would
have prefered probably Bishop g5 pinning
the night but III was played Bishop h6
should be 296 a four ninety five ninety
to see five castles rook c8 should be 2k
eight yeah black is playing very logical
applying pressure on this diagonal right
here because that's where White has his
weakness and also does Bishop on a3 is
kind of a problem piece for white
because it's just not doing anything at
all in Queen c7 shove d3 d5 also very
logical move maybe g5 was even better
because now that this pawn is pinned to
the bishop
so certainly white should try something
like e for trying to go 3/5 and then
black can now play e5 or d6
but white lead Bishop d3 black to 85 85
and here are nice a nice missed
opportunity for for black what should
black to here
hmm
efore is not bad but then you go we
should be too and you not quite
winning materials so when you see a good
move we look for better Knight takes d5
yeah that just wind support and notice
that this doesn't help because after
this take here so d6 was played instead
Queen c2 I would have probably preferred
e4 Queen C to F for pretty logical you
know trying to open up the F file
so definitely logical in a way and now
black played 44 are very interesting
move
realizing that after it take twice third
Knight 64 and suddenly there are some
problems so it was probably better to go
back but then Knight 65 so II for was a
very nice move so it turns out that a4
was a mistake you know you had to play
for okay one night 63
and wrote xe4 so now block is up a rook
simply and the rest is pretty simple
alright let's look at another game
yes so who can tell us what would be the
best option for white here take only 5
yes of course
the ghosty 5 is met with a six it's not
as clear but de then take and then take
and if King takes you also to this but
in the game Bishop takes was played and
now Bishop g5 so for some reason why did
not take the pawn in this game night
each five g4 and now this was should
have been played okay so this seems like
a beginner game so we'll skip that one
for now see what happened here okay so
this is a Queen's Indian names Oh
actually I play this line myself with
bought with white knight c6 a3 Bishop d2
is kind of more common here but a3 is
fine to explain text normally Queen
takes c3 makes more sense otherwise
there is no reason for white to play the
Queen c2 line the whole point of going
Queen c2 is so that then we can take
with a queen and we have where the
double points but beat 63 is kind of
inconsistent so d6 was play d4 d5 h 3
okay a move is logical to try to stop
Bishop g4 but I think it's inaccurate
because what can black do now in this
position won't be a good move for black
take yeah because after this Socorro ki8
and even if you go to five first I think
you can still go night be eight and
still winning the porn so he played be
six should be three but if he was gonna
go be six then it would have made sense
to do that right away and not straighten
up these points so it's kind of
inconsistent play for block yeah he
should have done this idea without
taking on g4 of course as we kind of saw
in the previous names oh and here I
would have preferred this ship h4 trying
to play five and after this maybe even
this kind of SAC works because why not
threateningly 5f4 Rock f3 looks very
interesting but instead of that which
takes of six Queen decks of 65 de 95
Rock date but now blacks totally fine
has very nice pressure on g4 trying to
play c5 526 yeah here oh yeah this was
there's some 97 idea here so block by
Queen d6 oh and this one is very every
time you have f6 on h6 played you have
to be very very alert so who can tell us
what is white clay here
what should white play here at least I
don't know if that was played but which
should white play yes
very good sure page 7 and then 96 and
it's totally winning I'm wondering that
there's also a move to c5 but then I
guess you just take it doesn't see
because I have to check there see force
I don't think that works let's see what
happened in the games this happen in the
game this did happen and now I just
wanted to exchange 9h for going for a
night of 5 that makes sense
oh but blunder happened though or maybe
it was a sacrifice I don't know oh this
gets very interesting very double-edged
couldn't you 761 yeah um how would I try
to defend that position is still very
critical for black because rookie one
rookie 7 is just coming unfortunately
rookie 8 is met by Knight 67 for black
so how would we try to defend that
that's the good question
maybe it's ready tough position but I I
would think that black should still be
okay let's see
yeah I guess black is still losing yeah
do you have to go King f8 but still rook
e1 and Black is in trouble don't know
what the Black Stars sir yes so
amazingly enough it was probably not
better not to take on t1 which is a
little bit counterintuitive but here
it's already hard to say what did you
say 96 I think I'm still going rook e1
and I mean the problem is it's not just
these seven it's also h6 is hanging and
it's just a whole big attack King h8 you
know you can play rook e6 trying to
check the night it's just - when you
weak squares somehow procreate just too
many things hanging here
here we go Rocky eight here you go here
six
so yeah just too much yeah somehow yeah
this f6 h6 even here even you know
without a material advantage it's still
a problem so in a game c5 was played but
then g5 l g5 is a mistake as we already
said rook e1 was better but after c5
what would be after d5 black now has a
defense how can black defenders
Queen f7 96-86 that was now otherwise
that would have worked even in the
previous position
yeah well rook e8 night XG 7 it allows
another it stops one idea but it allows
another one so we need to somehow you
know King h8 still work you won mister
losing
there was only one wait 28 Windex g7 is
mate knight c6 um you're close but
slightly wrong execution because now
White has a brilliant way to win who can
show us how white would win after night
c6
um be better than night xh6 night xxx
might also be close to winning but it's
not so clear but a way to win just it
just winning six go 95 you know now the
light coats to get to defense and that's
kind of what black wants so again we
have to look two moves deep at least
here every line check capture threat you
have to look to move deep to move steep
yeah
just that yeah because now you can't
even go back and there is no really good
defense against the mate yes so that's
why again you know just because you see
Queen d1 you don't stop you continue
after King edge - and what does the
black do so that's why we don't go
knight c6 we go Knight c4 same idea 95
stops the mate
that's why g5 was a mistake it looks
like fine but now suddenly black has
that key five square and now rook e1 is
met with 95 so black in the game tried
white played d6 but suddenly white got
defensive chances black means or black
got defensive chances and now it would
be tempting to do this but unfortunately
for black you Queen here so you're still
losing here probably maybe not losing
but you know it's kind of bad because
after Knight of faith let's say Queen e7
you're gonna lose some of your pawns now
the white queen is too active
so King h8 Queenie 448 and now we got f4
and rook takes is 7 and and then finally
came Queen a8 so yeah this this got a
bit sharp in the very end but yes
well yes you can do that but that's
already slow I can go 96 I can start
fighting with at night and you don't
have time to get rocky 1 anymore because
I'm dealing with at night now you can go
there but then I can go King f8 and
working h8 and okay it's you still have
promising position but you're not
winning anymore
so there is their defence of resources
yeah so that's just quickly one second
okay so basically this is the position
is equal here yes so d6 95 97 King h8
Queenie for Rocky 8 a 4 and the others
position is equal but you have to play
Knight of 7 you have to just bring the
knight back and wide it's not really
better in this position it's looks still
dangerous but the thing is black also
has ideas but rope XC 7 was played and
probably he calculated up to a certain
point but maybe missed that Queen a
check very nice move in the end end and
now this is very easy winning
although ok wasn't the best technique
but still eventually white ones game I
assume
yeah so I mean now let's this last game
was actually quite rich so I was very
happy to go over it certainly some
interesting tactical moments so with
that game let's finish on a good note
and thanks everybody for coming does
anyone have any questions for me